today we're exploring the unknown
territory of tick tock
i can't wait what do we got
wait till the end i think this is poland
because i think i've actually been here
before it's do you guess sir
if i move forward does it
okay it hasn't been hurt thank god but
like i said i think this is poland
because if you look at the buildings and
the trees that kind of definitely pop
that's enough geo gesture
well thank god it wasn't hurt thank god
best performance to avoid nail cripper
clippers
literally my dogs do this they pretend
like they're just dying
and it's the worst thing that could
possibly happen to them
[Laughter]
taking my power away from me i have
nothing left
i watch over 400 anime i've only
given five shows a 10 out of 10. all
right let's watch it
[Music]
tara and russ never heard it get out of
here
skiddaddle it raised you give a raise
the tent
hand away your anime license i mean it
wasn't bad or anything
sure it was decent but my god at 10.
that's pretty cringe bro imagine giving
a race to 10
that's cringe i can't watch anything
else with this
mishishi i only read the manga and it
was really good
so you get the pass bakimonogatari gets
a 10
okay fine your enemy viewing privilege
is returned ah
all right nah not even funny get
yeah stop it stop it god the captions
always makes tick tock so cringe this is
insane look at this this is insane
all i have guys you can launch random
items like this rock
we used to make this in sweden actually
you take a toilet paper roll
you cut up the finger of a dishwasher
glove
you tape that bad boy in and um
get some uncooked peas and you got
yourself a machi
machine of mass mad destruction
kill gum
what is this
why [ __ ]
good morning usa that was that was the
same tick tock by the way
cool amazing riveting thank you what do
you
think it would look like if we mixed
among us and naruto
oh let's have a look at these results oh
what's the result
that's so cool amongst the naruto collab
finally happened
wow yo that's kind of sauce
that's kind of sucks i'm okay i'm all
good
there's so much of this on tick tock
what do you think about blue
apple apple apple
cat
was that his first tech talk or
something cat apple
apple
that is a cat you're correct apple
apple apple mouse
amazing i love tick tock what's gonna
happen with shopping give you a very
simple answer
alexa buy a purse did you want me to
find a purse
yes alexa buy this i just bought a 36
purse right alexa thank you stop alexa
the fact that i just bought a 36 dollar
purse in one second
nine seconds whatever the math will show
one second
uh nine second 11 whatever the record we
show
forget about ecommerce that machine
right there is remarkable
scott for
36 hey alexa
bye pewdiepie merch we're changing the
game here this is crazy
hey google okay google bye pewdiepie
merch
sorry i didn't understand changing
e-commerce
my god that took like what one second
get out of here
whoa my mind is blown the wisdom the
aspect ratio
really lends itself to tick-tock doesn't
he hey peter parker it's jacksepticeye
you got something for me i had to beat
an old lady with a stick to get this
funniest one so far no the dog was
funnier sorry jack
so apparently this person spent 400 on a
kaleidoscope
i didn't even know they had fancy
kaleidoscopes like me neither
but i'm excited to get a peek this looks
like a virtual world
this looks like a wardrobe world
[Music]
there's so many of these replies that
don't add nothing okay
i would have gladly just watched this in
a bigger race illusion right
this is like a world of war people
really call anime trash and watch stuff
like this
okay we got the new winner hell yeah
it's cole sprouse he looks just like
roomie
oh yeah one thing that you find on tick
tock a lot is
these young entrepreneurs okay they
figured out economy before there was an
economy all right
the power of branding a brick for either
i i don't know what that is well 0.45 or
huh whoa 150 watts
or rolex huh that's all branding the
rolex is barely quite anything and in
their watches
this is true for you too make sure you
brand yourself the best way you can
no [ __ ] way so you're telling me when
i buy a t-shirt
and it costs thirty dollars it actually
costs like what a dollar or less to
produce
i like this scruffy looking guy at the
bottom too
just going like [ __ ]
his mind was so blown by this fact that
he had to make a tick tock immediately
branding the [ __ ] how does that work how
does that work
bro i don't underst i don't know i'll
never understand it
look at kawaii konnechiwa watashi
nanamaya
boris johnson london shishu
shishu it's a new type of shoe where's
johnson it's shushing
okay i'm cringing so freaking hard right
now that your japanese pronunciation
isn't
perfect don't even try it okay i bet you
gave a raise to 10
you dummy all right i may have found
something that proves that the
government makes humans
all right every boy duet this and see if
you have that freckle right there on
your arm
is that a freckle that's a mole no okay
they all have it
no [ __ ] way dude
i must cut it out i must be a free man
no no bro look bro look right now
what my mind is blown we all live in
simulation
and elon musk created it this is crazy
guys
my mind is blown check out this tick
tock
nah you see the hoover dam is just
straight up proof that we live in a
simulation another simulation can you
build this
how you can't you can't build that
that's physically impossible i don't
care what nerdy
architecture stuff you have to say this
is not real
the hoover dam isn't real everyone thank
you tick tock for confirming once and
for all
the hoover dam is in fact a lie you
cannot build that
there's no way for you to divert the
river right
before you build it right right that's
definitely not i don't care about the
nerdy stuff that's super nerdy all right
that's too nerdy for me direct the river
can't do that that's nerdy stuff how
long should a guy last
how long should a guy last in bed two
hours
have you gone that long yeah hours no
no no that's ray william johnson
hours no that's not sex that's
the lord of the rings
bruh bro he's making tech talks
oh bruh i can't even look at this get it
away from me
that's a lord of the rings when girl
says two hours sexy i say
that's that's not even lord of the rings
lord of the rings is 3 hours and 14
minutes run time at least get out of
here
let's get out of ray william when i know
the difference between a ufo and a woman
driving turn your phone upside down
well i don't all right here we go
that's going to be difficult no [ __ ]
way dude
okay
that's good that's good women drive bad
get it that's
[Applause]
[Music]
uh what are you gonna do with that
alcohol david huh
again what are you what do you do what
you do with that whiskey huh
yeah yeah you slime ball you sleeze ball
that actually looks insane in person and
then it comes with this sick ass stand
now you go of course you got two of them
of course look at that it looks so clean
look at that can't wait for my friends
to get drunk out of that so i can get
some content
this game is so [ __ ] stupid oh no
ninja is sad
everyone go and say don't be saddening
yeah like the community these little
[ __ ] kids is just so dumb
it really is man it's not fun
[Music]
it's just not he doesn't like his the
kids
should i tell him or should you talk who
should tell him you know someone i think
someone needs to tell ninja
sir excuse me
do you have time to talk about our lord
and savior jesus christ
i don't run from the lord i've never
seen the puck run so fast in my life
jeez look what i found at target what
did you find at target bro
attack on titan that's an anime i watch
this is what gets in my feed look what i
found in a store
this is in a store look at this guys
it's an anime in a store
look what i found i found this i'm gonna
buy it
i could just torrented it online bro
come on put this in the store
look guys thank you let's all be real
this mf
ruined mr peace okay i've seen more than
one of these
of people hating on carl for no reason
and i don't is that carl he looks so
different
why stop hating on carl he didn't do
nothing
i'm calling out all carla haters all
right
y'all just jealous stop hating haters
they hate themselves don't worry carl
don't be sad
well tick tock hates carl and tick tock
is dumb dummy dumb
harrison ford finally reveals who shot
first can't win
you shoot greedo first or did greedo
shoot you first
um i don't care
[Laughter]
oh i want to be harrison ford when i
grow up thank you please
just one thing
oh my god now we know
for those star wars fans who don't know
in the episode
for harrison shoots glaucaya blog
first and that's immoral but tyron it's
disney you can't do that who shot first
who knows
what's the f kilo point
there's a lot of these as well people
reacting like
this isn't funny yeah you're not funny
either okay
no one's funny here there's no haha to
be made out of this
go away more and more minecraft stuff
gets you my feet we have another portal
like this and we like the center that
only one of the portals light up
but since everything's been kind of
glitchy at the wall we all know of
course let's see what happens when we
light the center up
while it's on the edge of the border
of course nothing happened nothing
happened nothing happened
nothing happened thank you for the tick
tock nothing happened nothing happened
thank you this is the thing like you
watch 15 seconds so you don't care
but it's so annoying nothing happened
okay
then don't post it
of course nothing happened oh you were
expecting
something from a video man from are you
expecting some
comedy or as interesting facts from a
tick tock
nah nothing happened nothing happened
people always ask me while sometimes
have a beer before i work out
and the reason is actually because of
something pretty interesting my doctor
told me
which is that i'm going to cover oh okay
[Laughter]
so some are funny i'll give them that
some are funny why are you just
burying eggs around the supermarket
[Applause]
[Music]
he didn't technically steal them because
they're still eggs
this is interesting okay but one day if
somebody knocks on your door
and claims to be your great great great
great great great great granddaughter
someone from the future going backwards
in time to meet her illustrious ancestor
don't slam the door perhaps in the
future
our descendants will have the
possibility of time travel
and perhaps one day they may come
knocking on your door
this is interesting dude if they meant
time travel
i'll doubt there'll be some dweeb all
right
yeah yeah my my seat did that they
invented time travel
that's all right sure i think i'll hear
about it somewhere else first thank you
very much
yo pewdiepie tick tock
let's go look at that ass
hell yeah we started with a b we ended
with the industrial revolution baby
let's go that looks so sick hell yeah
so sweet no she can then [ __ ] okay and
even if she did
super unprofessional oh my god the emma
watson i should add what's she like
feminism but i'll add a quote she'll be
like
not a lot of things can make me happy
but this sure came
[Applause]
not to be all fortnight bad but what is
this tick tock come on
i'm so confused big brain business movie
okay by tesla now what's really smart is
that this may be the business owner's
car this isn't known for being really
cost effective so it's cheap to run
also very likely to be marked as a
business expense and therefore
being a tax write-off you can ride off
your
car on your business if you put all this
[ __ ] on it
that's smart that's really smart damn no
one's ever done that before
thank you this guy just randomly saw a
business card and was like
this is a tick tock guys you can
you can save on your taxes guys you're
welcome
no way i better do that right now thank
you tick tock young entrepreneurs
yet again for teaching us where would i
be without
tick-tock economy tips i had a lot of
people asking how to do this so this
is how equip aeolitra then equip to
shields
oh no way then get some fireworks that's
it that's kind of cool
okay all right let's take that against
the pass
very nice i want to try that that's sick
the real reason to get vr
[Music]
he didn't bring up anime chips or
something get the [ __ ] out of here oh
economy advice about amazon products
you'll probably be surprised
so this popular phone case right here is
being sold for about 1878 on amazon and
this product right here is not
sold by amazon
amazon fulfillment center and all this
person's doing is selling this product
for
some high say hi okay product right here
buy low buy low i've been doing it all
wrong sorry
sell high buy low no [ __ ] way dude
get out of here
get the [ __ ] out of here you're changing
the game what was it again bye hi
oh god damn it
boris johnson london she
thank you for watching this tiktok
cringe edition hope you enjoyed
smash like subscribe
and i'll see you tomorrow bye